hey there townscapers and welcome back
to the channel
if this is your first time here welcome
and thank you for coming today
uh so today will be a little different i
received a request in my comment section
to build a quidditch stadium and for
those who don't know what quidditch is
i'll give you a quick
rundown harry potter is a series of
books and also movies
and it tells the story of a young boy
named harry who gets accepted in the
hogwarts school of wizardry
it's a big deal really in this realm if
i had to compare to something
it would be like the harvard of magic
high schools if that was a thing they
had a sport called quidditch and it was
like the soccer or i guess maybe field
hockey
but it was magic and flying brooms and
they would compete against each other to
be the champions of quidditch
there were actually quite a few stadiums
the concept was expanded and there was a
whole game dedicated to it it was called
the quidditch world cup so i decided to
choose two stadiums the french national
quidditch stadium
and the quidditch pitch um which were
kind of hard because i could not find
large enough perfect ovals for them
um but anyways that is my quick summary
there will be links in the description
if you want to learn more about it and
see the reference photos uh
thank you so much to sarah koro for the
request if you enjoy this please do me a
favor and hit the like button and share
this video with other people if you guys
think they would enjoy it
this will help me out a lot and i would
really really appreciate it if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more of my content please don't forget
to subscribe there's also a link below
that leads you to my channel so you can
see more of my videos thank you so much
for stopping by today i really really
appreciate it and i'll see you next time
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
excuse me but who are you
ruby is
[Music]
where your mom and dad
[Music]
you're a wizard
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
warriors
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
mmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is
go ahead